사나미 간다 오늘은 구독자 요청에
따라서 신 용산역에 와 있습니다
용리단길이라고 불리는 곳에 상권
분석가 그리고 빌딩 투자의 팁과 미래
전망까지 어 좀 영상에 담아 보려고
하는데 저와 함께 따라 주시면 좋을
것
[음악]
같습니다 신 용산역과 삼각지역 사이의
일대를 용기길이라고 불립니다 그래서이
용리단 길은 2 30대 분들이 좀
많이 찾는 그런 지역이에요 이런
매출도 굉장히 좀 높아지고 있고
그래서 오픈업 데이터를 좀 봤는데 한
4년 전과 비교해서 매출이 한 세배
정도 늘어났고요 그래서 그만큼 되게
좀 상권이 활성화되고 있고 젊은
분들이 좀 많이 찾는 어 그런
곳이라고 좀 보시면 될 거 같습니다
그래서 용리단길 일단은 여기에
기업들이 좀 많이 있어요 아모레
파시픽 있고 그다음에 LS 4옥도
있고 그다음에 유플러스 그다음에
이쪽에 하이브 4옥도 있거든요
대기업들이 요쪽 일대에 좀 많이
밀집되어 있어서 직장인 수요가 되게
좀 탄탄하게 있습니다 그리고 여기
일대 그런 초고가 주상복합 아파트가
되게 많아요 그런 아파트들도 많이
있으면서 배우 세대도 되게 좀 탄탄한
어 그런 지역이라고 좀 보시면 될 거
같고 제가 데이터를 보니까 이게 여기
인근에 있는 사람들뿐만 아니라
외지인들이 굉장히 좀 많이 오라고
외지인 비율이 오히려 더 높습니다 뭐
지금 직장인 수요뿐만 아니라
외지인들도 좀 많이 찾는 어 그런
곳이라고 보시면 될 거 같고 매출
데이터를 보니까 보통은 이렇게
직장인들 대상 상권은 주오일 상권이
되게 많아요 그래서 뭐 예를 들어서
뭐 역삼역 이라든지 선능 역이라는
이런 데는 평일에는 장사가 잘되는데
주말에 사람이 없습니다 근데 용리단길
같은 경우에는 오히려 주말이 더
높아요 거의 70% 다 2 30대
분들이 좀 많이 이용하는 그런
상권이고 여성빈 분들 비율이
압도적으로 높습니다 일별로 보니까
토요일이 제일 매출이 높습니다
그러니까 주 7일 동안 되게 활발히
움직이는 어 그런 상권이라고 좀
보시면 될 거 같습니다 시간대별로
보니까 보통 이제 점심 시간에도
사람이 많지만 제일 시간이 많은
시간대는
8시부터는 많이 오고 외지에서 여기
상권을 이용 하려고도 좀 많이 오는
거 같습니다네 그래서 제가 실제로
고객분이 여기 인근에서 매장을 한
10개 정도 하세요 여기서 개 하고
성수동에서도 하시고 앞구정 로데
오에도 있으신데 그분 말로는 여기가
제일 실속 있고 제일 매출이
괜찮다라고 하더라고요네 그래서 그만큼
제게 좀 되게 탄탄한 그런 상권이
아닐까 그 생각을 합니다 그리고 이제
신 용산역의 되게 상징적인 그런
건물이 바로 아모르 퍼시픽 사옥입니다
저는 태평양이 태평양 옥이랑 인근에
되게 낡은 건물들이 되게 많았는데이
건물에 일대 건물을 다 묶어서 어
이렇게 신축을 했습니다 그리고 제가
위치한 곳이 아모레퍼시픽 사옥 안에
들어와 있어요
전시하는 그런 것 같다라는 좀 느낌도
많이 받고 이렇게 이게 노출
콘크리트로 되게 잘 돼 있더라고요
그다음에 저기 위에 보면 이런 자연
빛이라는 이런게 좀 되게 잘 들어오는
거 같아 같습니다 그래서이 건물
설계하신 분은 2023년도 어
프리츠커상을 받으신 데이비드 치퍼필드
설계를 했습니다 원래는 이게
30층까지 계획이 돼 있었는데
치퍼필드 같은 경우에는 한 22층
정도로 층을 낮게 했어요 자기 철학이
담기게 어 설계를 하겠다라고 해서
그렇게 낫게 했는데 건물에 이런
실용성보다는 미관이나 이런 환경
도시와 이런 건물을 연결하려고 좀
신경을 많이 쓰신 거 같더라고요
그래서 그게 뭔가 아무래 퍼시픽 이런
회사 이미지가 맞다라고 해가지고
이렇게 좀 채택이 됐다라고 뭐 그렇게
얘기를 합니다네 그리고 아모레 퍼시픽
4억을 이렇게 좀 개방을 해 놨거든요
보통 이제 대기업 사옥이 들어가기
어렵잖아요 여기 아모레 퍼시픽 사옥은
이제 누구나 다 이제 들어올 수 있고
그리고 일부 층 같은 경우에는 뭐
식당이라는 카페라는 뭐 이런 뭐
판매점이 이런게 다 밀집되어 있어서
외부인들이 사용하기 좋은 뭔가 공공제
같은 어 그런 느낌을 주는 거
같습니다 이런게 좀 사옥 이미지에도
되게 좀 도움이 많이 되거든 그리고
많은 분들이 여기 와서 또 사진도
찍을 거 아니요요 안에서네 그걸 뭐
SNS 올릴 수도 있고 그걸로 인해서
사옥이나 회사가 또 홍보되고 하거든요
이런 사옥의 일정 층을 일정 부분을
이렇게 외지인 테 어 좀 이렇게 쓸
수 있게 하는게 저는 되게 잘한
선택이라고 이렇게 생각합니다네
용리단길 창업에 관심이 있거나 어
빌딩 투자에 관심 있은 분들은
간략하게 좀 제가 설명을 드리자면 2
30대 여성분들이 많고 그리고
직장인뿐만 아니라 외지 인들이 많는
그런 지역에 어 만약에 장사를
한다라고 좀 생각하시면 될 거 같고
평일 상권도 있지만 이제 주말
상권까지 고려해 가지고 저녁 장사할
만한 뭐 그런 아이템을 고려해 보시면
좋을 것 같습니다 그리고 좀 뭐 빌딩
투자 측면에서 좀 말씀드리면 뭐 일단
거기가 되게 노화된 건물들이 많거든요
만약에 건물을 뭐 신축한다고 하면은
경계가 이상하게 돼 있는 경우는 되게
많아요 내 건물이 옆 땅을 침범했다는
아니면 옆의 건물이 내 땅을
침범했다는 뭐 이런 경우도 있기
때문에 반드시 좀 신축할 때 좀 그런
부분을 좀 사전에 건축사 님한테
확인하는게 제일 정확한 거 같아요
그리고 삼각 지역 쪽에는 지금 정비
구역으로 지정이 돼 있어요 개발이 안
되거나네 그런 부분도 있기 때문에
토지 이용 계획 반드시 출력해서
보시고 개발이 가능한지 어 체크해
보시면 좋을 것 같습니다 뭐 자세한
분석이 만약에 필요하다 인근 임대
시세라는 건물 매각된 사례라는 상세한
내용이 궁금하다고 하시면은 이메일
주시면 제가 답변드리도록 하겠습니다
용산 인근에는 호재가 워낙 많기
때문에 뭐 투자 가치는 더 높을
것이라고 좀 예상이 되고 지금 뉴욕
같은 경우에도 보면 센트럴 파크
인근이 제일 부동산이 비싸거든요
그리고 한국 같은 경우에도 도산
공원은 앞구정 서울 수분 성수동
그리고 이제 용산 공원 개발은 뭐
용리 단기 공원 인근으로 좀 이렇게
상권이 많이 발달돼 있고 사람들이 좀
그쪽 인근으로 많이 찾는 거
같더라고요 제 개인적으로 봤을 때는
용리단 길은 용산 공원 바로 같은 블
블기 때문에 그거에 대한 영향을 좀
많이 받지 않을까 그렇게 좀 예상을
합니다 그래서 개발 호재가 워낙 많기
때문에 용리 단기를 좀 유심히 보셔도
좋을 거 같고 앞으로 좀 어떻게
발전할지 그리고 인근의 개발 중인
그런 건물들 있잖아요 그래서 만약
그것까지 들어오면 저는 아무래도 그쪽
인근이 좀 더 상승할 여지가 좀
있다라고 생각을 하기 때문에
여러분들이 좀 계속 지켜보는 지역
중에 하나로 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다네 구독자 요청에 따라서 어
신용산역 분석을 좀 해봤습니다 어
여러분들 도움이 많이 되셨나요 또
만약에 궁금하신 상권 있다라고 하면
언제든지 댓글 남겨 주시면 어 제가
찾아가서 상권 분석을 하도록
하겠습니다 어 제 영상이 마음에
드셨다면 좋아요 구독 눌러 주시고
댓글까지 많이 남겨 주시면
감사하겠습니다 다음 시간에 뵙겠습니다
빌딩은 빌사남
[음악]